[Musique]
et oui avec un footsie nanar et nabila
d'ailleurs un oui c'est moi qui avais
oublié mon shampoing avait une belle
petite équipe a un nom mais c'est vrai
dans un instant on parlera tout ça avec
amélie pourquoi tant de haine
ma vie locale est avec toi l'hélico
j'aime beaucoup elle le sait je l'invite
à chaque fois parce que c'est une jeune
fille que j'apprécie humainement je
trouve qu'elle est très long court
toujours respectueuse à les sympathiques
elle est de plus en plus jolie non mais
c'est vrai et elle a écrit pourquoi tant
de haine
amélie neten alors vous parlez notamment
dans le livre ce qu'il ya un truc qui a
si le train pouvait un peu tard mais ça
vient si vous pouvez vous le [ __ ] dans
le merci les faits ça chez moi c'est
vrai qu'on bat merci franchement vous
respectez thierry s'il vous plaît merci
à mais les volutes dans le livre
notamment que la prod2 secretstory avait
insisté auprès de vous pour vous marier
avec senna dans la maison à vous a
proposé un deal assez fou et vous aviez
demandé à voir de l'eau chaude illimité
non mais en fait à l'époque quand on
m'avait dit pour le mariage
une fois qu'ils avaient pu de près mais
cet arrêt j'étais au confessionnal et
jeudi mais je ne marie pas puisqu'il
avait déjà lancé toute la procédure a
non mais je le dis dans l'île
vous avez été obligé de vous marine en
effet pas obligé parce que aller pour
fait quand on est enfermé depuis trois
mois tu sais plus ce que tu dis tu sais
pas ce que tu fais en fait tout
simplement c'est comme eux et du cou du
coup voilà et puis après ils ont dit
mais tu veux quoi et moi j'ai dit
bellevue l'eau chaude et du coup mais
voilà c'est ça va être quand vous êtes
mariés contre le lot chaude et autres à
schwedt limon ont fait un gel dit on a
été un petit peu des pentes à 2 d'obama
mais je ne regrette pas en fait je
crache pas valable parce que je dis
merci
moi j'ai un pote qui a divorcé pour un
quatre colloques le holy ça tombe sur le
coin de ta gueule lattes et dites moi
comment vous faisiez pour faire l'amour
dans secretstory à l'abri des caméras
ouais c'était compliqué après moins de
néons
on oublie qu avait des caméras donc du
coup ils nous laissaient tranquille ah
oui au fait comme jean michel merde
annoncé au nom sans écho je les fais
démarrer la petite sur nrj 12 un truc
qui m'a fait des marines mais les anges
c'est elle qui a produit les anges c'est
la cohue mais bon là l'animateur quand
même
alors ils m'ont pris moi à dire sur le
casting j'ai l'impression qu'à l'époque
vous entendiez très bien servir des
bruines j'aimerais vraiment vous
entendiez bien les deux matières josset
de ouf regarder on arrive
la rasd a récemment souvenir pour vous
mature et s'adresse à vous souvenir
oui oui oui oui oui vous l'aimez bien
amélie ou pas franchement j'adore pour
moi c'était la meilleure des candidates
de télé réalité ça c'est prime là
c'était très difficile parce qu'en
revanche elle était odieuse comme dit la
vérité mon coeur pourquoi vous dit qu'il
y avait une coupure pub et tout ça elle
sent à l'aise je pars c'est fini
maintenant je reviens plus on pataugeait
terminé merci beaucoup et gérer vos amis
ou même aux inversions est toujours là
les chéris juste amélie neten pourquoi
tant de haine qui jeu qui va peut
acheter le livre d'amélie qui parle
aussi voilà deux voilà tout ce qu'elle a
subi sur les réseaux sociaux
voilà et ella ella ella elle a souffert
amélie l on parle dans le livre c'est
vrai il n'ya pas que les réseaux sociaux
ça a été beaucoup plus loin ouais ouais
moi mon fils justement voilà ticket
retenter franchement gilles verdez enora
d'accord les autres n'ont même pas ton
c'est certainement intéressant mais bon
j'ai d'autres choses en ce moment on lui
a mis la tête pourquoi tant d aide aux
éditions michel lafon